le judo mondial a posé ses valises à
versailles à l'occasion des championnats
du monde de judo des sourds la
compétition créée en 2004 se dispute
tous les quatre ans cette année
l'édition versailles et affiche un
record de participants gymnase mont
boron aujourd'hui on a 26 nations
différentes qui viennent du japon à
l'est jusqu'au chili à l'ouest et
principalement d'europe d'europe
centrale et d'europe et ça fait cent
soixante quinze athlètes plus une
centaine d'accompagnateurs donc à 280
étrangers l'événement est programmée de
ce jeudi 28 octobre à ce samedi 30
octobre il a été organisé sous
l'impulsion d'un homme d' ami antoine
champion du monde de judo des sourds en
2004 aujourd'hui ce judoka est
professeur à versailles et directeur
technique internationale pour lui la
frontière sur les tatamis entre les
valides et les sourds heymans
nom d'une autre manière une autre forme
adaptateur tu en as tape une autre femme
cela ne fera pas
la principale difficulté se situe au
niveau de l'arbitrage et la
communication avec les athlètes on est
obligé de voilà de leur signaler en les
touchant que ça commence ou que ça
s'arrête mais ce sont les seuls les
seules différences par rapport à une
activité valide classique beaucoup tac
au tac pour coûteux comme une catégorie
à part un contact et les plates menthe
et habitera elle peut toutefois être
papa par la fin du tournoi est
programmée ce samedi 30 octobre avec des
compétitions par équipes ce jour là la
seule devrait une nouvelle fois affiché
complet
[Applaudissements]